Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Oh,
right.
Welcome to another episode of your mom's House podcast.
We have a lot of business to get to,
but we have a lot of show.
Thanks for,
for sticking around.
Get get,
get,
get to know.
Good to go.
How that is.
Hey go dude,
dude.
Dude,
dude,
dude.
Where's our sound?
Why is there no sound?
Oh Gee.
The final weekend
of odd ball.
I'll be at the shoreline amphitheater Friday.
I'll be at the Irvine Saturday and then Fart next Sunday.
If you're in any of those cities.
I'm doing the odd ball tour.
It's been a lot of fun.
Uh,
we'll talk about the Texas run here in a little bit,
but I'm really a good time.
Then I go back to regular old,
not amphitheaters and um,
I got to just those lowly lowly clubs and normal theaters and things like that.
You know,
where you see people normally perform.
I have a very special show in Ontario,
California,
one show only one night,
only October six.
Then Charlotte,
North Carolina,
October 13 through 15 Cox comedy club in San Francisco.
Saturday is already sold out.
Um,
that's the 22nd.
So you can only go Thursday or Friday right now.
A New York,
New York,
Caroline's,
Jude Oric,
titties Carolines on Broadway.
Uh,
two shows already sold out.
You got to hop on those.
Raleigh,
North Carolina and then Louisville fill her up.
Delphia yeah,
we just added a fourth show at the Trocadero.
Please get those.
And West Palm beach coming to see you.
Blessed Harry Paul West.
Harry palm come in to see you in December.
Genes.
What do you got?
Oh my gosh.
Big Deal.
Seriously,
this is it.
This is the week I start my tour.
I'm,
I'm out of retirement at a baby retirement two in one night or September 27,
Tacoma Comedy Club.
Uh,
September 28th,
I'm at Portland and helium.
October 4th Hyenas in Dallas.
October 5th,
Houston at,
shh.
It's a secret group.
Say that.
The thing with hyenas,
and I didn't say this before,
there's two shows,
7:00 PM and an 8:30 PM one is in the plan.
Oh,
room and then one is in the regular room,
the Dallas.
It's like,
it makes no sense,
but now there's a 7:00 PM and the planet and then eight 30 whatever.
October 5th Houston,
October 23rd two shows in the same night.
Yeah.
Uh,
seven o'clock and an eight 30 at hyenas comedy club in Dallas.
Tay Hos,
why are you doing to ship and this,
I know different,
different rules,
different rooms.
Once in Hannah's and the plan.
Oh,
room and then one's in Dallas Room.
It's that makes sense then it makes no sense.
Makes no sense.
But a,
if you want to come to a seven o'clock,
go to that one.
If you want to come earlier,
October 23rd Indianapolis,
mortise,
Comedy Club.
October 24th Cincinnati,
go bananas separate.
Ninth and 10th a DC Improv.
How exciting is that?
That's it.
There you go.
That's what I got support her.
Jeanne Esti.
It's a Royal Royal Gina,
Steve,
if you're in any of those cities,
so farty today and yesterday and the ranch.com for her counsel.
Guard outcome for me.
Thanks for the Fart note.
I'm going to bring so many farts.
Oh guys,
if you shop on Amazon and I hope you do,
please use our banner.
Uh,
go to your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Click on the banner at the bottom of the homepage.
Do Your shopping as you normally would.
It just kicks back some change to the show.
It makes our lives better.
Yeah,
there you go.
Alright,
just do this.
Oh my God.
I can't wait for the,
you know,
I was listening to the show and there was all these ads and it's like Joe Rogan
dose like three eggs.
Yeah,
there he goes.
Three hours.
Don't you guys to at that guy does.
If he does it,
how come you can't do it?
I don't know.
How come you put your whole fucking head up your ass hole?
How come you can't have both way out of it?
Why don't you put both thumbs in your,
your Cujo and pull them apart and then show us,
sent us a picture of that.
We'll put her on the show.
That's our answer to your question about that.
They'll show us the inside of the hole.
I know,
I can hear the tears coming.
Can't you timed it?
15 minutes.
I mean 15 minutes as well.
Here's the thing,
an hour program on television or if you listen to radio,
but they have way more Joe.
And he did it to a just today and he did a three hour show and he's like,
this is not as good and you're not Joe.
And he didn't know he only did two ads.
Why come?
Why come you don't do like he do?
Well,
why don't you bite the end of your dad's Dick off and then,
uh,
like smear the blood all over your face.
Make a video and then we'll play it on the show.
Yeah.
Wanting to answer coming your dad's boss.
There you go.
Your Dad and your dad's butthole at him hearing.
Yeah,
there's the answer.
That's the answer you've been looking for.
That's all your dad falls.
Okay.
Are you upset?
Still good.
Hey cry.
He didn't change your diaper.
So many.
I don't even want to hear him.
I don't understand how fast forward works.
Scroll,
you know,
scroll,
motherfucker scroll.
Hey Mo.
Oh,
by the way,
we're talking to like the four people that messaged us like 200,000 oh,
sorry.
It's
ain't going to hit.
Are you going to hit me?
I had to.
Mine's on.
Mine's on airplane.
Look showing you why is on airplane showing you it's your fault.
I Dunno.
Well,
mine's on airplane.
I couldn't have made that sound.
All right.
God dammit.
Oh,
it's you.
I don't know.
Of course it's you.
It's not me.
I want an airplane.
Let's start the show.
I'm so excited.
You know why you don't fuck your friends?
I'll tell you why.
I tell you,
boy,
you find them hideous.
That's why you don't fuck your friends.
Okay?
Don't bring in one loving to this.
Well,
go to your mom's house,
Christina visits.
Yeah,
I tried something new with the sound earlier.
I was told that if I did this quarter inch to eighth inch line and set up,
it would be better and it didn't sound as good.
So I went back to the old setup.
We also don't have the habits of the new board yet either.
Oh,
should we got an old barn?
I see it right there.
Yeah.
Well,
why don't we hold it for the new studio?
I mean,
why bother setting it up here?
We're just going to move in like three weeks.
What if this,
this is a p this is,
I don't trust this thing anymore.
I wanted to burp and then there was barf under it and I didn't,
I don't trust this anymore.
Why is that?
What failed us?
Yeah,
that's the,
Oh,
the cable did the cable did we got a new cable in there,
but it's not.
Yeah,
but the board is,
but well,
it's a cable that came with the board and this board is kind of Dog Shit,
Huh?
Yeah.
Then I guess we got to set that shit up.
I need an engineer to come over.
Yeah,
I'd like that too.
that'd be great guys.
We're so stoked.
We were going to move into a new place.
Yeah.
We're going to have fucking dope ass studio and it's a little while here.
Way better than we are.
Way Better.
It's much more advanced than what you guys are going to shit when you see it.
Yeah.
No.
See that's the kind of Burp I thought I was going to have.
Yeah.
And then there was too much vomit under it and I didn't want to push it.
Yeah,
sure.
You want to keep that couch in that room in the the room.
Why?
Because you can't put like,
you can't like kicky foot up.
Did that couch,
just so you know the sound studio we're getting.
Yeah.
It's a real studio.
The Guy,
the guy,
the guy who owns it owned.
Is it?
He's a composer.
Composer and he scored movies and famous people.
He told us Michael Mann said on the couch.
I Richie diarrhea.
Richie Guy Ritchie.
Oh,
I'd like,
I thought you said diarrhea.
Richie ice cube.
Ice Ice Poop.
Yep.
Can you believe Guy Ritchie was married to Madonna?
I know.
How horrible would that be?
Yeah,
he's the right Khan.
He's a right cut a fire.
Yeah.
So every ball is a right can't,
but that couch has like stories to it.
Right.
And ice cube farted on that couch.
Yeah,
you're right.
It's got the wrap or foreign.
It's a weird stain on one side of it.
Did you see it?
Yeah,
there's a weird stain.
What color?
It's just like a,
it looks like it has some type of water damage or something on the left arm.
Right.
So you're telling me you don't want the couch?
Well,
not because of that.
I was just thinking of being able to relax.
You know,
it's a relax room.
Oh,
you want to go in there and dad down?
Well,
I thought we would,
we could watch movies in there also.
Like,
do you want that to be the movie watching couch?
Well,
here's a good point that our real estate lady said is that that couch fits in
there and you know that it fits there.
That's true versus the unknown.
But here's what we can do.
The day of moving.
We bring our shit there.
Yeah.
And we test it out.
And if we don't like it,
that company that we use,
they take away to stuff you don't want.
Yeah.
So like no harm.
Okay.
No harm.
No fart.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
I was going to say it the same.
Yeah,
I know you and I are like,
you know why you don't fuck your friends?
I'll tell you why.
I'll tell you why you find them hideous.
Okay.
That's why you don't fuck your friends.
It seems like he really has thought about this.
It's smart.
You know I love her,
but you know what?
She hasn't thought about getting a haircut,
a haircut and a proper support Bra.
Oh,
cause you can see her tits are not harnessed in,
yeah.
Maybe the whole new shirt [inaudible] magical.
It's again and off.
Yeah.
There's like,
I don't know.
It looks like it's been,
it's like that spray paint style,
you know,
like a mall.
Yeah.
Like a mall made shirt and there's stars and shit.
Nah,
I don't like it.
But her tits are real sloppy and they're moving around.
Let's see what she has to say.
I think she might have more to say.
Oh yeah.
Lie to them and say,
well,
my family,
you move.
Yeah.
Why don't you fuck me?
Do you think that the thing is that she's desperate?
Like is she making this because she's not getting laid?
Yeah.
It's kind of angry.
Right?
She's on the receiving end of that fight.
Just like,
why don't you fuck me?
That's really the agenda here.
Yeah.
What'd you fucker fucker?
No,
I'm being don't,
don't just why not?
Of course.
Cause like she said she's hideous.
What if it's her?
I'm giving you permission.
Yeah.
You have to fuck her.
No,
I got it.
No.
And anybody else?
Do you have any other suggestions for fucking are Guatemalan Nanny Bay?
What is wrong with you?
That's the whole point.
It's a hard one.
It's a,
would you rather,
it's the essence of it.
So fucking horrible.
Horrible.
It's supposed to be black hoodie.
A bank.
She's like,
look at her like a grandmother.
I know.
That's the point.
Which I couldn't,
I couldn't,
I'd take this animal to doing these videos.
Animal.
That's such a dad old dad thing.
This animal.
Well she is,
my dad says this fucker animal.
That's what I,
yeah.
Friendly relationships with people.
Look,
you're two adults.
You're not related by blood.
It sounds like somebody is not returning her advances.
What she's doing.
What happened?
Here's what can I tell you?
My theory on this woman,
she has a,
a friend,
she's attracted to attract a friend.
This is all her inner thoughts coming out that she's never,
she's wanting to tell this one friend who she's been dying to fuck.
Yeah.
And for her it's like this makes sense.
Like the logic is there for her and that's why she's spewing this out.
But that friend doesn't want to Fucker,
you know,
at all.
Like there's not even any reciprocation.
It's such an easy fix.
I think.
Just a little bit of makeup for this lady at a support Bra.
Yeah.
Maybe some therapy.
Clearly.
Yeah.
You got to work.
So he got some shit you got to work out.
Especially if you're posting this on Youtube.
Yeah.
It's real bad advertising.
This is
real.
Like,
uh,
like it's like a bad Facebook posts,
but worse,
cause it's,
it's you actually on video saying things.
Imagine her,
all of her friends that see this,
they're all like,
oh God.
And he's saying it or whoever.
This is far.
Yeah.
I don't want to use pronouns.
I don't want to assume.
Well if I were to guess pronouns,
I think she's talking to her.
I don't think she's in the,
he's,
I don't think Zur is in the Sims,
if you know what I'm saying.
Hey,
I'm wondering what's your Pronoun but this cute little thumb rings.
He's one of those dudes with summaries.
What?
What's up Russ respects somebody.
Do you know that we've gotten some emails in the academic world.
Um,
hold on.
Hi.
We're doing one wide shot today,
which is why we're like,
we got to say something.
Hi.
Hello.
This is how we're doing it today.
We have no blue band of blue band is working on another project and this is to
kind of save time in post.
Hello.
Anyways,
we've been getting these emails from act people in academia and now it's,
it's becoming the norm.
Somebody signed off so you got like professor of the psychology department,
Pronouns,
Zim or he his whatever the fuck.
I think the craziest one.
I'm going to start doing that.
We saw him one,
it was like Roger and something and then it was like pronouns.
He him his,
yeah.
That's what I thought Robert.
That is typical of a cisgender.
It is,
by the way,
in some privileged,
I don't know if you've seen this,
but for a while now I haven't made any anything about it and I don't really get
any attention for it,
but I've been very high.
This is my look at my,
uh,
this is my Twitter bio.
Oh,
I've seen this comedian
tweets from Tom signed fart.
I love it.
You know what?
They always do that for super famous people.
It's like tweet from Tom Cruiser,
sine t,
all the,
all those like really famous people have like their team manages it,
but like if Barry Obama side,
it's like,
well those will be signed to be,
oh,
you know what I love is when people think you're famous enough to have someone
managing your social media.
It gives me a thrill.
I know.
I don't know who manages your Twitter account.
I'm like,
gene,
either do I get in touch with them?
Like I said,
on Facebook all the time ever really reads this.
The truth is,
I don't know,
because I hate Facebook emails.
So I checked them like once a month it'll full inbox.
I'll skip over them.
The worst,
the worst Facebook message,
you got to see this and a link.
I go,
Nope,
I'm never gonna look at it.
Because for some reason the video never loads quickly like it.
It's like,
uh,
I also don't want to take that chance.
What's the chance of,
of like spending time seeing something I don't care about.
So if they describe something in a meet an amazing detail,
but when it's just like,
this is hilarious,
don't care.
Yup.
And nine times out of 10 it isn't,
it's not something I've been sent.
Okay.
Jesus Christ is my n word.
We've been sent.
Oh my God.
We get sent that daily to the show,
to your mom's podcast@gmail.com and that's a fake thing.
So we don't play that because we are aware.
It's stupid.
But I'll tell you the people that send us videos,
big words to the show,
they're funny.
Yeah,
those are great.
A lot of good ones.
Not like you're dumb friends.
You know.
The Shit.
What was I going to say?
I don't know.
You got to see more of this lady.
People pretend to care about like you know,
it's like these poor people who have down syndrome,
you know,
like,
like eat all,
they're put into this world and nobody's going to fuck with him.
You might have people who are like high function,
it's not true.
And yet these people go,
oh I love these people,
I take care of them every day.
And I have a good friend who is,
who's east high function you has down syndrome and I feel like saying um,
did you find them?
Did you bought them?
Did you,
did you blow it?
Did the guy could probably really use a little below.
Did you see a movie?
She's,
she's got a lot of dark.
Let anger and see only cares about blowing down.
By the way,
that's our biggest problem.
I was sent a link to,
I think the show's called born like this and I watched it.
I was,
I can't believe how misinformed I was on like the,
your assumption of all downs people that like the how articulate and and and
high functioning to,
to borrow from are our friend here.
These people were like two of the Lane married one.
The guy,
they were like,
are you interested in dating?
He's like,
I don't want it.
Like he talked like that I'm not interested in dating a girl with down syndrome.
And they were like,
why?
He was like,
honestly I'm not attracted to it.
Like that was the level of the conversation that he didn't talk funding at all?
No,
there was no like a affectation.
Nope.
It's pretty nice to you to take it there though.
But that's what we're having.
We're having a nice time.
And then everybody listening is thinking because you ordered,
cause you're talking like you're talking normally and everyone in their head is
translating it to retarded when you straighten your arms.
Wow.
That guy's,
that guy's,
that guy's not retarded.
That's,
that's the best part.
Let's go guys functioning.
And he just,
he just makes himself returners.
Nice,
Nice.
Everybody's thinking.
I'm just saying what the listeners?
No,
no,
the answer is no.
They were like,
he talked,
he talked like Tom Segura.
I mean,
I wouldn't take it there.
It wasn't like guys
like you're all,
would you fuck a down syndrome?
No,
no down syndrome girl or her.
Honestly,
this,
this lady really scares me.
I think there's some real severe look out.
I mean that that looks like when you see somebody that killed somebody and they
do a mugshot and you're like,
especially when it's a woman,
you're like woo.
And they show that.
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
I see that Eileen Warner,
there's,
there's just darkness and her man angry.
You know what this is like a,
like an East Coast d like,
you know,
some of them are just so angry just because they're born the east coast
and they were like,
we don't have Starbucks.
Really have Dunkin donuts and there's no sun.
No Sun shine here.
Oh your mom's con.
Yeah,
the citrus is terrible.
I know she's mad cause she can't get a decent avocado on the east coast.
Everybody gets mad about that.
Fucking blow him.
Did you fuck them?
That's really,
that's a really look for that to be your genuine perspective.
No,
not at all.
On the normal regimen.
And that's probably on the list of things a downs person is concerned with.
Like they fall by the way.
That's the other thing you should've put.
She's wrong about,
it's wrong.
She didn't she have a lot of sex.
No,
I didn't download caffeine anyways.
Every time this thing goes asleep,
I get 25 messages.
Get Caffeine asshole.
I know.
And I keep forgetting.
Okay.
So
or so grumpy today.
I know.
Um,
I,
I've had my foot up here.
Okay.
Uh,
yeah,
she's,
she's grumpy.
Uh,
very [inaudible].
Normally how many sick a straight women,
straight women who,
who write the trying to understand core lesbian.
Do you want to understand what you want to help me?
Okay.
Do you want,
you want to help me?
Any straight women out there link my con,
lick it until I calm in your mouth.
Didn't
do it for you
is a really,
this is the equivalent of some really sexually repressed dude.
Yeah.
Women are fucking assholes.
Something like that.
Like it's a lot.
She's that aggressive.
She's like,
she's like a dude that's upsetting.
It's like a bummer how upset she is.
It's not attractive to the what part.
Okay.
Is it all the physical features that are thrown together?
Oh,
is it the attitude?
It's the attitude.
Yeah,
because honestly somebody in the world would find her physically.
She's not physically,
she's talking about after an adventure and like maybe like digging through some
caves.
There would be someone that we could find that would fuck her.
You said somebody in the world,
I'm just saying that they're not around probably that much,
but if you kept searching and you got like a like a group of people together and
it was one of those things where you went,
you know when they have like 70 people walk through the woods and they each have
a flashlight,
like a search party,
then they can find the one person that would fucker.
I got what you're saying.
Yeah,
you're right.
You want to be helpful.
Straight women open up a nice little lesbian sexual clinic.
Go in there and dress up in a nurses out there with the shortest skirt and you
can come in and go,
hi honey.
Time to get your spine reach back.
Then you wouldn't be kicked out of your rubber Mommy fucking rubbing my face.
Yeah,
so attractive and she's really crazy.
I feel like I need to tell her,
you know how you're going to get laid.
Not that like I need to help her.
How's,
how would you help her?
First
of all,
right
lick Kublai Khan.
First of all,
she's a positive attitude.
Lesbian or not?
No one likes a Debbie Downer.
Like it doesn't matter what you do.
And then maybe change the tee shirt.
Maybe we're a bra.
Yeah.
I mean I don't think she wears deodorant.
Do you think she would be like,
you know what?
How about I buy a new t shirt at all?
Fucking wear some makeup and then all you gotta do.
He's like my country.
She,
she really throws it out there.
She does.
Yeah.
She's aggressive.
Do you remember that one time when we were in New York City for my 30th birthday
we were with Shauna and Joanie.
Thank you.
And we were in the,
what's their park park called?
The big core central park and dumpy.
Remember it's been stuck in my brain for 10 years.
It's a woman who walked up to us and she wanted to,
she bumped you want to bum a cigarette and she was wearing a shirt with the
shirt tee shirt with no bra.
And she was young too.
Right?
That's what stood out.
And she was young.
She was in her 20s.
Cute.
But there were like sloppers I remember just being like,
I bet like for 20 bucks.
And he's like,
Hey,
he my asshole for 20 bucks.
I bet she'd be like,
all right.
Now she's like,
can I bum a cigarette?
You're like,
if eat my ass hall.
Do you think she did it for a cigarette?
I think she was uh,
you know,
down enough on life that you could have been,
you had to ask her anything.
She was down online.
Oh,
she looked really,
really like she was bummed out.
Like she didn't belong.
It feels like a runaway.
Wow.
You really remembered her.
Yeah.
Cause I was like,
oh my wished her team would take a walk so I could see what I can figure out
what this chick,
you know,
cause her tits.
What was neat about and why it sticks out in my mind,
it's the way that they moved.
Like you ever seen when the ladies,
the burlesque ladies with the tassels.
Yes.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Just from walking the walk.
But they went like this boom,
boom.
Until they didn't,
they didn't sync up.
Right.
It was also one of those things where the four of it was the four of us,
we all are to turn crazy.
Everybody saw it.
And it's rare when four people notice the exactly like triple J's on a 21 year
old girl
and like Shauna and I,
the bus station for days now I bum a cigarette.
She did not say that.
She looked like it.
She did.
And I was like,
why don't you give me a fucking blow job?
Jesus.
No,
I,
you're so aggressive,
bitch,
sitting over here fucking lick my can.
You know what I was thinking?
Emotional problems.
Right,
right.
That's what I felt like that I could use one of those.
She's very repressed.
Yeah.
She's angry.
She's really,
really
mad.
She's seen so many beautiful women that weren't attracted to her.
Yeah.
But it's her doing it is,
but you don't see it whenever anyone like everyone's,
I don't know that everyone,
but like,
and whenever you're frustrated like that,
yeah.
You texted while to separate and sometimes some people never see it,
but it's not other people.
It's you and your perspective.
Yeah.
Cause there's someone for everyone.
I've been there,
I've been in that position sitting it,
not like I didn't wolf shirt,
but I've been in like,
this sucks.
You know,
sitting and sitting around in the apartment and then you're like,
well why not me?
But you're not going to figure it out in the apartment.
You got to get out of your apartment because you want,
you want to know why you're all fucked up.
Yeah.
Cause your friends are fucking loser because the fucking bumps you hang around
with.
Well it's true though.
It's true.
It's her negative and her negativity is just going to repel.
Other women and you have to hang out with that.
It doesn't matter where you are in life.
You can't be around negativity.
No,
that is the kiss of death.
I agree.
It's like negative people that are always always complain and our downs,
every shit on everything and everything sucks and fuck that person would tell
you those people are poisoned,
man.
Yeah,
show me your friends.
I'll show you your future.
Yeah.
Dan Pena said,
and you're sitting around your apartment like,
cause the thing is I get out,
don't hold up a little.
Changed her attitude.
Go for a walk.
Go for a walk,
go to the bar,
Go meet other women.
I mean there's someone for everyone yet another wolf shirt.
Get another wolf shirt.
Put some,
get some hairspray.
I'll wear fucking makeup.
He'd dump cond you've lived my cotton.
I'll come in your mouth.
That's a cool thing.
That's really aggressive.
So she said,
Hillel fucking common your mouth when you,
oh my God,
my face.
We're talking about a woman,
but women have dark thoughts like that too.
Of course.
Do you have that,
those,
those thoughts sometimes rub that,
rub those big tits in my face or like why don't you stuff,
you're digging my mouth like that all the time.
Really?
That's how I think.
So I go check.
When you're frustrated,
you're like,
why don't you to stuff your balls in my mouth.
Like some guy behind the counter and you're like,
this guy's good looking bulls and my mount you stuff your fucking balls in my
mouth on train them.
I don't think I've ever,
never the kind of right kind of,
yeah,
like I want to like the meat and the potatoes,
the dog in the bath tub in my mouth.
But you as a woman do women,
do you have those thoughts?
Sometimes aggressive sex.
Yeah.
But that's usually in the act of,
or when you and I are ramping up all it was talking about.
Okay,
let's talk about fun,
aggressive.
Let's get,
let's take me out of the equation.
Let's say like way before we were together.
Did you ever have like 14
years?
Right.
But let's say you're,
you know,
I can't remember that far.
You see in the guy,
he's,
he's wheeling the trash bag.
Oh,
and you're like,
yeah,
like he's wheeling it back to the curb and you're like,
why don't you stuff that?
No,
no,
no.
Why not like that?
I don't,
not that angry.
She's angry.
Sexual.
Yeah.
She's so hard up that her horniness is turned into rage.
Right?
Like she's angry.
Horny.
What gives that away
lick?
Because my con lick it.
I don't think I've ever been angry corn.
Yeah.
What about you when you see that lady in front of the Vons and she's missing all
her teeth,
but she's got that sign if she's got some free kittens.
Yeah.
And she's,
her face is a little dirty and her beard is grown in just the little at her
tits.
I Dunno.
What the hell was going on there?
Stop again.
She doesn't want one.
Why is that about the close?
What's going on?
I don't know.
Hold on.
Oh No.
Why is this stop
one too?
Um,
all right.
I don't know.
He's had some weird technical thing there with our,
fuck me man.
But it's recording.
Okay.
Yeah,
it's recording.
It's fine.
I just got scared.
I got scared.
Did you pee in your pants a little bit?
Back to my question.
Yeah.
You see the lady in front of Vaughn to the sign?
And she's got the free kittens and her beard is grown in and her tits are a
little loose cause they're not in a bra.
Yeah,
she's probably smells pretty bad.
Did that doesn't stop.
You know,
that's the thing.
If you paint a different picture without the smells,
I can,
I can probably approach it.
The smells are too much.
So I've sat,
I've walked by those ladies.
She uses this smells overwhelmed.
So one of those ladies or lesbian,
both lady,
I think this lady might murder someone.
She's,
she's so a horny.
Yeah,
she's horngry.
But she also has,
um,
empty soulless eyes.
Yeah.
She's mentally ill.
That lady without the teeth and the kittens.
She's a little,
she's nurturing a little loving,
but she's got to take a shower.
What if you brought her home and we show her no.
Why?
I don't want to bring her home.
A hotel.
The hotel.
I take her to a motel.
Motel?
Yeah.
It's not worth the hotel.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah.
And then I'd be like,
Hey,
hey,
here you go.
Here you go.
Here's a few bucks.
And then you'd have to shave up or coach too.
It's all fucked up.
Yeah.
Um,
what,
how has your beard coming back in?
It's not good.
No,
it's good now.
It was bad last week.
Yeah,
you got all fucked up.
Your beard got all jacked.
It got all fucked up.
But now your beard's growing back in and it
starting to look good.
What do you think?
Tell me how you feel.
Um,
I'm feeling pretty,
I'm feeling better.
Every day is better.
He really fucked me up.
Uh,
I can faint.
He jacked it up to you.
Look fucked up.
It was really funny when you came home,
it was really your face.
I'll never forget your face cause your eyes really were like Ooh,
he got ya.
What happened there?
Got Ya.
Every now and then a hairdresser gets,
they get ya.
Yeah.
Every now and it happens.
It just happens here.
I'm going to do a poll on Twitter.
I just thought about this.
What's the poll I'm going to do?
What should I name my tour and I have I think three or four options.
I know you what?
Stan Ama.
The standard.
Mature
stand up.
Yeah.
Um,
stand Stan standing up.
That's pretty good.
I liked staying tomorrow but I don't know if that's going to be in mind about
fuck my beard.
My beard.
Beard fucked.
I'm beard fucked.
I got beard.
Fuck.
Do you guys my beard sucks.
Suck.
Beard.
Beard smells.
That's a I like beard smells.
Oh my God.
So I like beard smells.
I've always liked that one.
No,
I was thinking hell to the Nah as the tour name.
I like hell to the na.
Yeah.
Okay.
So what are your front runners?
Okay,
here we go.
Here they are.
Yeah.
They are my hell to the Nah,
uh,
verifiable as a tour name.
I don't understand that one.
It's a play on a couple things.
It's like,
you know,
it's checkmark like,
yeah.
Yeah.
This is verified.
It's verifiable.
Yeah.
It's also,
I think a play on this sincerity.
Like,
cause I could see someone doing that sincerely like verifiably good.
You know?
So it's like kind of a joke about that.
Like,
um,
yeah.
Give me the check mark.
Uh,
fresh on parole.
[inaudible] is one and then I have no teeth,
no entry.
Those are my leading tornado.
What do you feel in your gut?
I think I want to go with hell to the Nah,
I liked that one.
Hell No.
And you just got your theme song.
So when they bring you on stage,
yeah.
The health of the norm.
All right.
You guys,
are you ready for your headliner?
Yay.
Ah,
here he is.
You've heard him on your mom's house.
You've seen him jerking off in alleyways.
Give it up for Tom Segura.
Hey guys,
what's up?
Yeah.
Who sings this is this.
Who Sings this bishop?
Bullwinkle they should run.
Yeah,
I think this is great.
And then your poster could be dressed as the bishop.
Yeah.
How about,
what if I call suit?
What have I called my tour?
What is bullshit?
I love watch this bullshit.
I can't put it as the toy,
but that's a really fun.
Why Not Watch this bullshit?
Bullshit.
What was the best clip?
Where were his other ones?
So funny.
He goes,
watch this
guy.
He's so drunk to work.
The best is that when that happened is there,
they're there in North Korea and they were doing your presentation state dinner
for him.
Yeah.
And then he grabs a Mike.
He carry boxes.
Bullshit law.
So loaded term drunk than a deck.
Oh my God.
Uh,
oh.
I guess there's also,
um,
I'm Pauley and I'm by,
oh,
that's a good one.
No,
the poly and by tour.
I know,
but when people are going to be like,
wait,
that's too confusing.
If they're not fans of the show,
I know.
It's like when you do a standup show and then podcast fans just yell,
shout or you Paulie by,
you know,
and you're like,
I can't,
I can't right now.
You don't like a beard?
Smells I liked beards or smells is good.
What is amazing?
Oh fuck this.
Great.
Amazing.
It's so good.
Oh Man.
You want to know?
Well,
I think,
I think the answer you have it.
I think it's held to the na.
Yeah.
Did you write down my,
my,
my time.
Okay.
I did kiss my pussy would have been good to
kiss,
kiss my printed on these tickets and everything.
I think that's even funnier if you get a ticket and it's like the kiss my Pussy
Thompson represents kiss my pussy.
Yeah.
Or golden voice or whatever.
Presents,
uh,
the kiss my pussy tour.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Hmm.
Yeah.
That's a good one too.
What am I,
what am I top ones again?
All right.
You got hell to the,
Naw,
you got verifiable.
Fresh on parole.
No teeth.
No entry.
Yeah.
I think that's top for,
see now I like fresh on parole.
So do I.
You know why it made me laugh when you just said chuck,
and it's always a good thing when it makes you laugh.
Yeah.
But hell to the Nah.
It's so dumb.
It's dumb,
but it also has,
it's catchy,
right?
Yeah.
That's a silly name.
Hell to the nine.
You can play that song when you come out on stage.
I might be able to even book bishop Bullwinkle somewhere.
That'd be fun.
Yeah.
To sing it up fresh on her role.
It's stupid.
It's very stupid.
Which amuses me a lot.
Yeah.
Fresh for all.
Wow.
You know,
it's tough.
This is one of the toughest decisions we've ever had to make.
Make a branch and get over it.
That's what I got to do though about this.
It's like,
all right,
well I'll tweet that out if you want to vote for me,
but okay.
Alright.
Look what's here.
It's a quarter of a piece of bread that I didn't eat last week.
Somebody pointed that out,
I think in a tweet or something.
Oh yeah.
I don't know why I didn't finish.
I don't know why it's still here.
It's really hard.
You were talking earlier about,
um,
Dan Amoss a Ma,
you know,
and how standard must on a mall,
how it's important to have stand on my,
um,
the standard.
My kid put together some raps.
Oh,
cool.
I think he's rapping.
Someone said to me he is rapping about social injustice possibly.
Okay.
That's kind of exciting.
Let's hear what he has to rap about.
Can't wait to hear your raps.
Stay Anima.
It is my desire.
Yeah.
Mom's desire.
My desire.
Mm.
Kay.
Quit with the [inaudible],
the bitching
[inaudible]
on the fake artificial world.
Everything's aren't a phish show.
All of these nerds going to tap it Victoria secret and they complaining they
don't have money because they spend money on these twitch hose because they
can't control their desire.
But then the minute you call them out,
it's politically correct.
You're a woman.
Hated massage.
Dennis.
This is political correctness up the ass political correctness.
Is that the son of the lady that wants me to liquor con or no,
cause I see a lot of similarities.
Yeah.
Including hairstyle.
Oh,
anger.
Yeah.
That was that.
That was not his best verse.
I don't think,
no,
I'm not inclined to continue,
but,
um,
do you want to hear one more verse?
Possibly?
No,
I think he needs to work on it a little.
Yeah,
maybe
just work on it.
He talks about words in the second verse.
Okay.
All right.
Let's give it a listen.
I can't even,
I can't even look on my computer screen because they want to castrate me and
crucify me over some,
and political incorrectness can't even use the word slow anymore because it's
wrong and they need to take it out the dictionary for these people want to take
everything out of the dictionary because everything's offensive to them.
Okay.
Do you know what I was thinking and a correct me if I'm wrong.
Yeah.
The one thing you really need the rap is flow.
He's got,
he said,
that's what you're saying,
right?
He's got it.
He's got the look.
Yeah.
You're saying he's got that.
So you're saying he's got the,
the one thing you need.
Got It.
He's got the hair.
Yeah,
he's got it all.
Lyrics,
check,
flow,
check video.
She got an email about the poop pile.
Oh Bullshit.
Your poop pile.
Who
mix dog
Brown dog coming off makes me laugh every morning
and says,
hey jeans.
I just wanted to pile on the heap and the Pooh story debate.
I am inclined to believe Tom because on boy scout outings we would do something
similar.
You were supposed to dig a sizeable hole.
The being fascinated by fire and fucked up stuff.
As teenage boys we would use sticks,
leaves or we would,
we could find a sizable sheet of bark to move the poop and do a mound.
We would then set the very flammable methane life shit stack ablaze best Ben
Jeans.
It's not exactly,
it's not exactly the way you described your poop pile.
It's not exactly the same,
but name is similar.
I'll tell you why.
You at one point lied and said that you had a ladder and that you guys would
climb up the ladder.
I said,
ally and hang your ass is over the ladder and then shit.
Awful ladder,
which is almost impossible to off of a ladder.
A ladder on a tree.
You know,
it was like,
no.
There were steps.
Someone hammered into a tree,
you could climb up a makeshift ladder and then on the tree there was a like a
seat,
like a ledge.
You could sit on and shit from the tree or you find that this is so stupid and
that you keep adding to it.
Adding till,
I'm not adding.
Why would you do that?
Why would you go through the trouble of building a makeshift ladder on a tree?
Yeah,
so you could climb up it and then she boot pile.
That's a lie.
You think,
ah,
I like that.
And then people would,
they would drop with either the children would come running for miles,
they would on the poupon.
They loved it.
The kids loved it.
And neighborhood kids,
you'd see it.
They would drop their ice cream just to do it,
you know?
Okay.
It was really not,
I know.
He was really fun.
Yeah.
Officially line.
I'm not guys don't believe Thompson Gora.
Yeah,
I'm leaving this guy.
You got another email from a listener that says,
Hey,
I know my,
my husband is now using a double pipe.
Classic excuse to Fart all over the place.
Thanks guys.
I played me both.
I want this to stop.
No more double pipe.
Classic mythology is low and loose,
Jess.
Okay.
Wow.
Yeah,
yeah.
This year it.
See I can't do that with moving on to the room.
Right.
I feel like it's too,
it's too much for him.
Yeah.
I'm his mother figure.
I feel like he can't see,
can't handle it.
Not,
yeah,
he doesn't have the standard.
The standard.
Yep.
You heard it first here.
Sorry.
Blue Band.
No farts.
Hi Mommy's.
I'm a huge fan of your show as well as mommy jeans.
That's deep,
Bro.
Weekly Jam.
That keeps me sane.
Thank you.
Normally I wouldn't chime in,
but after that,
after listening your last podcast,
I had to say something you guys were talking about naming your next born Carl's
Jr.
Well,
I am a woman.
I forgot about that.
I have a one and a half year old daughter who's exclusive.
Nickname is just that I nicknamed her car when she was just a newborn and
somehow it morphed into Carl's Jr.
My super uptight mom always has to throw her 2 cents in about how I'm screwing
up my kid and giving her gender identity issues because of this,
I say in an era where people name their Kids Cherries,
waffles,
tennis and apple race car.
Whatevs this nickname is totally acceptable considering she has a normal girl's
first name for all intents and purposes,
which I typically call her in public.
My hope is that you guys can weigh in on weird family nicknames you were called
and ones you plan on embarrassing your kid with also.
Am I fucked up?
I fucked up.
Parents were calling my kid this hilarious nickname.
What's the long term damage?
Thanks.
Love y'all.
Zooey um,
I have to say you're talking to nicknamed fanatics 10 nicknames for everybody.
If it's a problem,
we're in trouble.
So we have a lot of nicknames for ourselves,
for each other,
for drugs.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
we actually,
many of you know our good friend Ryan Sickler,
I started calling him sickle cell 10 years ago calling him sickle cell.
No you didn't.
And I called him a with,
sorry.
Sorry.
You need to get your life because that was mine.
No,
no,
no.
I've called them sickle cell the longest mine.
You're lying.
No,
no,
no.
Not you like your claim things that I did.
I called him sickle cell after sickle cell anemia.
Dave.
I know what it's named after.
I know what I had called him.
Of course.
I remember when I told it to you.
You do not remember when you told it to me.
No,
you laughed and then you go,
we can't call him that.
That's so inappropriate.
That was fun.
He's a comedian.
It's fine.
No,
you're so crazy.
You're going to,
What are you talking to?
I came up with sickle cell.
You don't even know what sickle cell anemia was at the time.
What are you talking about?
Okay.
Anyways.
Oh my God.
Okay,
let's ask sickle cell.
let's ask him.
I'm going to call him right now.
Yeah.
All right.
But he doesn't know who invented it.
I don't think maybe he'll have a recollection.
I think he's going to say it's me.
Well,
that's what you're claiming.
So I would assume that you think that,
but then how does he know who invented it?
Cause I could have told you at home and then you could have said it first to him
and then he thinks you came up with it cause you were the first to say it.
You seem you have a reputation and we'll just,
your or your reputation is a shaky memory.
So I don't think it's,
first of all,
that's so fucking bullshit.
What?
You're such
a bullshitter.
Your list smiling because you know you're lying right now.
I think it's so funny that you,
everything that I say you're like,
I thought of that.
I said that for her.
It did say that first.
Okay.
All right.
Oh my God.
Fucking hope he answers be does too.
How come?
What's going on?
Okay.
It's horrible.
It's not going to answer it.
Some weird Skype.
Okay.
Dammit.
You're so,
so full of it.
I named him that.
Tony's been four.
I thought of sickle cell.
Okay.
All right.
So I'll just give you,
I'll just give you that bone.
So Christina,
oh my God.
Heard me say something and then said that she did it.
Oh my God.
You're such a shitbag.
Next you're going to say you came up with El Chapo.
That was mine.
Oh,
though is mine.
Chap Pito is yours.
El Chapo.
I called him El Chapo first.
The baby,
right?
Oh John.
I'm the queen of nicknames and songs.
And you even told me that you're good at it.
Yes,
thank you.
But you didn't come up with sickle cell.
Oh my God,
you didn't.
you did.
That is one thing I know I came up with his sickle cell.
You did not.
You're such a shitbag.
You are liar babe.
Oh my God.
I'm embarrassed for you.
Where's your fucking water?
Water Champ.
What are you drinking?
That's not water.
Yeah,
it is.
It's salted flavored water.
I'm the real watershed.
Zero Sodium,
by the way,
zero sugar zero.
By the way,
when I,
I got a lot of tweets from people who saw your shows in Texas reporting back to
me.
You had no water on stage.
Okay.
I did have water on stage,
but you didn't talk but you didn't touch it.
Right,
right.
So,
okay,
if it was 2100 sets,
so what?
I don't go 20 minutes without hydrating.
Well look at your Yorkie sieve.
It doesn't matter.
I do frequency.
Now let's talk about nicknames.
Did you have any embarrassing?
Let's go back to this and not about all right.
You named them and say go sell.
Um,
so the point is we call our friend sickle cell.
Oh my God.
Which is for people that are,
that don't know what's going on.
And then they hear you go like,
hey sickle cell.
Like believe me,
we've seen people turn hell.
Even one of our friends heard the nickname,
ended up working with Ryan somewhere years ago.
Saw Him and yelled out in an office setting sickle cell.
And she said this guy popped over the uh,
there was like a cubicle and you went like sickle cell.
And then Ryan was like,
uh,
that's what they call me.
Like had to,
cause I came up with it.
You thought it was so offensive.
You wouldn't say it for the longest time.
I called Ryan sickle cell first and he went and then you hopped onboard.
Okay.
That's how it worked.
Remember,
remember
Moreau when you went to the,
and then they're like,
as a lot of cabinet
dabbling.
Me Too.
Oh my God.
It did happen to ruin you.
Studied in Spain for a semester.
And I know I did not do that.
Such a dad laughed.
Now can we talk about this topic though?
I like this idea.
I know what your parents called you.
Let's see.
Last year,
I know you're coming and turning into your time.
Starting at the top dog.
I know your parents called you the king of the dumps.
King of the dumps.
As My,
my dad calls me,
he calls me big dog.
Yeah.
Uh,
for a while was it like when I was a kid was Kaka maker.
Uh Huh.
King of the dumps.
Um,
yeah.
You know,
stuff like that.
They call me Chris Tucker.
Yup.
Christa law as in a horse.
There's some rhyme and Hungarian.
She got,
Whoa,
whoa.
Oh,
that's right.
Tell people what that song means.
It means the snow is falling.
The horses are farting and the the littlest or worse taking a shit
that's a Hungarian like a,
it's like a children's song.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
there is a time where we call each other little at the end of it,
like crystal low,
poppy low.
So they call me Chris Crystal.
Why?
Why did they call you that?
I forget low.
We just add it because that song was around our house and she got home,
Christy low and we were just singing a lot.
So I became Criscuolo could he see low?
Oh Krista,
Krista Potsy,
which is a horse to [inaudible] low energy.
You do like a lot of times you walk kind of horse like not true.
Yeah,
true.
We kind of have a go.
I got prancing horses kind of walk.
I feel like not true.
Yeah.
I have bird energy,
bird energy.
I'm more of a bird.
I like to perch and I look like a bird more.
Yeah.
I don't have and I have dog energy.
Like a Brussels horse legs though.
You have horse legs.
How the thin and beautiful,
no,
it was a very shapely,
muscular and strong.
Yeah.
Why are you making fun of me?
How strong I am?
Because I've seen you do squats.
You saw me doing them this morning at 5:00 AM yeah,
we got a lot of nicknames by the way,
for our son.
I know,
and I just ate what I did.
And guys,
if you have children,
I recommend doing this.
Open up an email account for your kid and then send them emails when they're
babies and then eventually,
you know,
they can read all this stuff.
And actually at the same time that you started doing that,
which I think is wonderful,
I'm going to send him an email as well.
Please don't.
Why he doesn't want to hear from you.
He told me.
Okay.
Um,
Nathan Timbol comedian
sent us a letter,
sent us a book.
It's called,
it's okay to talk to animals and other letters from dad.
So he's a great comic buddy.
My used to live here and he wrote,
he wrote this book.
It's a collection of letters that he wrote to his daughter is the same day you,
you started doing that?
Yeah.
It looks like Nathan's wrote written a bunch of stuff.
Oh,
he's got a bunch of shit.
Where can you buy Nathan?
I just go to Amazon,
amazon.com look up Nathan,
Tim,
t I m m e l m.
And this book is called,
like I said,
it's okay to talk to animals,
but he also has,
it appears that he has one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
10.
Holy Shit.
Publish things.
I'm good for him.
Yeah.
Go get us this stuff.
So anyway,
trouble has a few nicknames.
El Chapo Chipito Peto Jay
little jeans,
baby jeans.
And lately it's been,
he's been called scale bops.
I call them scale.
Bopper.
Skeeto bops.
Skiddle Skeeto bops cause he scuttled labs around now,
which is adorable.
You I call stinky farts.
Shit.
Beard.
You don't call me shit.
It's a lie.
You call him.
He usually jeans
Shane's Tommy,
Tommy Salami.
Yup.
What else?
I call you hearts.
We call it her farts.
Align
farts.
Yeah.
I call you Tina.
Mommy.
We call it your mommy.
Call you Tina Mommy.
Yeah.
Gina's sloppers Ticketmaster monster.
Ted's monster.
Did she do call me a lot?
It's fun.
Uh,
sweet hangers.
Yeah.
Um,
I dunno.
I think that's about it.
Kissy face.
Kissy jeans.
Yeah.
That's a lot.
The dogs.
I'll have bitsy Schnitzel.
Yeah,
I call her bedclothes souls.
Bit Souls.
Yeah.
The beds and then fee fall.
FIFA Roney Pepperoni,
Pepperoni for rally.
Yeah.
Sandra Chelsie show is my favorite.
Kelly is the dressmaker on my big fat gypsy wedding.
Yes.
I see.
Yeah.
And so we were calling him a FIFA rally.
Sondra Chelly.
[inaudible] that was fun.
Fifo stakes.
Like yesterday,
he yesterday really panicked and all that.
Yeah.
He panicked and he admitted this horrific smell.
Yeah,
we read about,
that's I guess a normal when duck cause he gets anxiety when we were only gone a
couple of hours,
we left wrong.
We left all at once in front of him and he panicked and he also was a room.
Got Dark.
Oh,
that's a big reason.
Yeah.
Bissell's wakes up like
La,
la,
la La.
Did you leave man?
Normal.
I know she's still valid.
How
are you ever back?
I thought you left forever.
Am I going to the shelter,
by the way?
I think the Carl's Jr nickname is hilarious.
You can do it.
Absolutely.
You can do it and you can't call me a horse.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm great.
Now look how high my self esteem is.
You can definitely let it go.
Say it a lot.
I mean,
you know.
Yeah.
That's funny.
Rip just at home,
just as long as you don't make that her her fulltime name.
Yeah.
Yup.
And please let her define her pronouns.
What is her pronoun?
Got To ask?
It's it's child abuse.
If you make a baby,
have pronouns.
Yeah.
You know what's interesting?
Speaking of baby jeans,
what's that?
You and I went to our first baby class together.
Really Fun.
Really enjoyed it,
right?
Yeah,
no,
no.
Was to now we've been to two and you pointed out how annoying it is that some of
the other parents are rude.
Yeah.
That they don't even acknowledge your existence and say hello.
How you doing?
Eye Contact Ligo?
Is it that fucking hard to just say hi to the other people?
There's like nine of us.
Yeah.
I know.
Some of them are you like you're,
you're all sitting in a circle.
You're the kind of people that make an effort to take your baby yeah.
To this kind of thing.
Yeah.
And,
and then like you're,
you know,
you see their kid,
you're like,
oh,
like what's,
what's his name?
And then they'll say the name and then they don't ask you what's your kid's
name?
Right.
It's Jimmy.
And they're like,
all right,
this is like a
playtime.
Yeah.
So rude.
I mean,
you don't even have the God damn manners
to make a,
you know,
polite chatter.
What do you,
what are you looking for?
I'm trying to figure something out.
Don't worry.
What are you figuring out something?
Jesus.
Does it sell me?
No.
Oh,
well,
but it can be,
can we go and do that?
Yeah.
You want me to pull it right now?
I'm so excited you guys.
It's been a long time.
And I got very nervous that are Persian lady had disappeared on us because the
last we heard she was putting bags in the trees figured it out,
you know?
So
I wanted to know what that Farsi Labors
Tricia,
she went away for a long time.
June is in part Jews.
I thought she definitely pick it like I thought she didn't realize is the
running number on her phone to me or the person who's leaving never hears back
from whoever.
She's kind of,
I don't think whoever you're contacting,
how about you just,
you guys aren't friends.
There's no love there.
You
sexted for.
Thank God that sounds good.
Sound,
sound
funny
element.
Tell me,
tell me.
Tell me about him.
Tell him,
tell him,
tell him.
He said to me,
it's such a good song.
It's by Jordan Wolf and it features Brian Daza.
It's song.
It's called Solomon Shorten.
Wolf.
[inaudible].
Thank you very much for that.
Um,
anyways,
it happened.
You got it.
I've got one on Thursday and now it look at the last time she,
she voiced mailed us was June 14th,
so it's,
wow.
It's been a minute.
Three months.
And I,
yeah.
And I was convinced that and that our,
our thing was gone that we work on.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
I mean,
thank goodness.
Well,
let's hear it.
You want to hear it?
I'm dying to hear it.
I haven't listened to it.
Just save it for the show.
Hi Louis.
[inaudible] man.
[inaudible] and thank you for your target.
Men have a job,
but maybe
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] thank you for your thoughts on them.
Again,
this is my home number and called me selfish away.
Whoa.
That's two different conversations happen.
They're clearly,
yeah.
She was leaving a message for Sallie Mae.
Yeah.
And then you could tell that she talks on the phone to somebody like Sallie Mae.
I'm telling you something.
And then she was like,
oh.
And then she goes,
this is my,
like you can even tell how the,
her mouth goes back to the phone,
you know,
like she's talking to her.
It goes away.
Hi Louis.
[inaudible] and thank you for your thoughts.
But men have a Gel
[inaudible] that matter doing.
Man.
I'm Marla.
Marla,
thank you for your cross.
Sell them again.
This is my home number.
You can call me.
Thanks for your talk.
Salamay wow.
So it looks like they've been talking again.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Apparently not about phone numbers at work in the work.
Nope,
not at all.
Um,
anyways,
so we all went back.
We have a number of listeners that,
uh,
speak Farsi,
that,
that translate for us.
So hopefully one of you will listen to that and send us a translation.
Your mom's podcast@gmail.com please put in the subject title.
Salamay translate.
I'm so curious to know what's listen to her in the last three months so much.
We don't know.
We know that she put bags in the trees to keep the squirrels away from eating
the figs for meeting the,
is that what it was?
Yeah,
yeah.
Somebody sent me a picture from like,
I dunno,
reddit or something of that practice of that being done somewhere.
You know,
that's a a thing that people do bags over the figs,
the fruit trees.
We got to 30 plastic bags on it,
so it's totally crazy.
Then the do.
Yeah.
You May as well let that doesn't make or immigrant move for sure.
For sure.
Yeah.
Remember when you're,
you told me the story of your Nana.
Yeah.
Um,
she couldn't believe there were lemons,
so she's squeezed every single lemon from a lemon tree.
Yeah.
In a,
in a Ziploc bag and then put them in the freezer.
So your freezer was just like full 50 Ziploc bags of lemon juice.
And you're like,
what?
So my father,
we had a lemon tree back in the house we lived at,
this is when I was a teenager and she lived in Canada at the time and she grew
up in Hungary where they never saw citrus cause of communism.
There was no fruit.
So she came to La to visit us and also the climate,
right?
Climate.
Yeah.
She could not believe we were wasting free citrus lemons.
So she juiced and I mean it took days and she juiced every single lemon and then
put the juice in a Ziploc bag,
a regular old zip lock,
and then put it in the freezer.
Now she used the freezer that was in our garage that my father used for Fresca
and beer.
Like,
you know,
he only has like a fresca and beer.
It's a real dad move like that.
And she took out all the fresca and the beer and just stocked it.
Oh,
I didn't realize it was that much.
I mean I'm not,
it was bags.
What'd your death thrilled when he found out
live it?
Fuck,
are we going to do the fucking lemon juice?
I mean,
I don't even need the shit.
But what happened was,
so she took the lemon,
she made lemon cakes,
lemon juice,
lemon bars.
She uses everything.
And then she went back home to Canada and we had these bags.
And sure enough,
my dad actually ended up making lemonade a lot.
So it was a good thing.
And we used them for years,
like years later.
Fresh lemonade is delicious.
Certainly is Tom.
But what a pain in the ass to make hate lemon bars.
I hate lemon.
Lemon cake.
Lemon cake or 11 Marangu I hate limit or key lime pie.
All loving grocer.
I hate keyline so,
so,
so
you know what?
I hate
lemon bars.
I fucking hate lemon bars and I fucking hate orange marmalade with like the
orange peel in it.
Why do you want to eat that flavor of of Jam Orange?
[inaudible] I'm not a fan.
No mind the flavor.
I don't just want the the Ryan,
I'm sorry.
Maybe I'm a child.
But if I,
if I'm going to put a a jam,
a spread on something,
I like strawberry.
Yeah.
Gray but bras raise grapes.
Great.
Yeah.
Roster is good.
Raspberry.
Maybe that's it.
I don't like the seeds in the,
in the jelly.
Yeah.
I like,
I like apricot.
Anything.
I must my fave Rake Martin.
A strawberry Marmalade.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
We'll take like,
you know,
six hours or something.
No Shit.
Yeah,
I remember doing it and it was,
it was so delicious.
Looking back though it you would just take like cups of sugar,
right?
Have this boil going that free God.
But it was incredible.
I wish your mom would do that stuff.
Now I know she's a little tired.
You eat things like I would never put these together.
She would take toast.
Put butter on it.
Yep.
Put that strawberry Marmalade.
Yeah.
And then a piece of Munster cheese.
Yes.
That was like your dad would do that too.
That's a very like foreigner tree.
I never saw that in most American households.
You know what?
My Dad would pack for my lunch for Sam a lunch.
It would be butter and jam.
Strawberry jam and butter for a sandwich.
Yeah.
Or butter and Salami.
I mean,
is there anything grocer,
he's a God damn.
He's a cockroach.
That's an animal.
Yeah.
I mean,
how can I trade?
I couldn't trade anybody for that piece of shit.
Sandwich.
No,
and then I can have like chef Boyardee butter salon mater as Leilani.
Your stomach would hurt.
Oh my God.
These are so much grease.
Yeah,
that's really rich.
Greece and Greece.
Nice.
Healthy lunch.
I mean and then a can of Ravioli chef Boyardee it would be like orange electric.
Yeah,
that toss.
I liked it.
I still like it.
I,
I was still eating it,
but I knew it wasn't terrible.
But how you guys operate and I'm nervous because I'm leaving tomorrow and the
next day.
And you're going to be along with the baby jeans.
I'm terrified.
He's going to be,
his fingers are going to be in all the sockets.
I'm going to be like a one off mistake.
Yeah,
give him some steak and feed them hot dogs and Shit while I'm gone.
Sausages.
Oh my God.
I already told the our nanny to make food for him so that you don't,
that's what he's been doing.
I know you got to keep an eye on him,
right?
Yeah,
I can,
you know,
watch it and I'm going to watch.
He's my son.
Of course.
No.
Oh my God.
You're nervous.
Yup.
You have to change his diaper and stuff too.
I do that.
All the where the same one all day talking about.
Did you tell him let's do a little horrible or heinous.
Ready?
Hilarious are horrible when do that.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Let's see what we got here.
I see where this is going.
Cigarette.
Yeah.
Some tells me no.
What's he doing?
He's got a big open flames last stupid idiots lit up.
Oh No.
Oh.
Wow.
Oh my God.
You didn't laugh.
No.
You know why it went to a,
I got scared for him Saturday because I had a friend who in college would light
his hand on fire when we were drunk as a joke.
He would put rubbing alcohol on his hand and then the light it and then one
time,
of course he burned himself.
Yeah,
really badly.
And
I can look at the joy in your eyes.
You haven't been that we went to the new house today and I didn't see you smile
like you just smile.
Yeah,
right.
We just bought a house for the first time.
All right.
Look at the joy in your eyes.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm being serious,
Tom.
This look in your eyes.
The Joy.
The smile in your eyes.
Yeah.
You don't get that anytime else.
Then when I see somebody get hurt,
yeah.
This is crazy.
This kid.
I hate it.
I don't want to see it again.
I picture us.
Holy Shit.
No,
that can happen so fast.
Ooh,
he's
lucky.
His buddy was there to help him
fight
this fire.
Pick it up.
Yeah.
Fire is nothing to fuck with no dude.
And you know,
boys love to play with fire.
I love to play fire.
When I was a kid,
I should,
you know,
I went to high school with a kid that was,
uh,
convicted of arson.
Really?
Yeah.
What did he set on fire?
Florida State University.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
He,
he set fires there.
What a dummy.
Yeah,
pretty crazy.
Oh,
is he still in jail?
No,
he got out.
He got out.
Um,
he got to years ago,
but he,
I think he may see,
he probably did like three or four years.
Oh my gosh.
Tree.
Yeah.
So he's just set the school on few set fires on campus and he got busted.
Yeah,
I get it.
You know,
young boys and fire.
Yeah.
They just love it a lot.
I mean,
he wasn't that young,
you know,
we say,
well 19 something like that,
you know,
your brain's all fucked up when you start setting,
uh,
buildings and stuff,
you know,
start setting fires in the library.
Um,
I'm sorry,
where the library,
yeah,
you can,
you know,
he could have killed somebody.
Absolutely.
This isn't like little,
he wasn't doing,
oh,
check out this little gag I'm pulling here.
He was trying to set deliberate fires,
you know,
why know,
cause major damage.
He,
yeah.
I'm saying like he had real,
real issues.
Real promise.
Yeah.
My homeboy,
he wasn't,
it wasn't doing well.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
I know it went to sleep behind me
anyways.
It's probably because you're so thirsty and dehydrated.
Yeah.
Oh,
what?
Um,
hold on.
I'm going to,
I'm talking to a sickler even sickle cell name that I came up with.
You're going to lead him,
right?
Yeah.
Ana,
you're leading the witness.
You're leading him.
I'm not leaving.
He's going to say you because you're his best friend and you're asking,
I'm not asking.
No,
I'm not.
I really,
I really want to get an honest opinion from him.
He might,
you know,
might say the,
uh,
what you think,
you know he's not,
he's going to side with you cause you're as dumb boyfriend.
But why?
Why would he do that?
Because you're his dumb boyfriend and you're going to lead him.
Okay.
Let's just,
the Yana,
Yana I want to get,
I want to get the honest take from him.
I really sure.
Okay.
I do.
If he gives you,
it gives you,
it gives the crown to you.
I'll accept it.
Okay.
Gigi alums do hat.
Can we remove the,
the bread though?
No,
he likes it.
He says I can call him.
Let's see.
I know
you guys are both near texting him right now.
I know.
Say I say I made it up.
Okay,
you're texting him right now.
I'm going to fucking God.
You better submit those texts for transcript text.
Gianna,
I'm the court.
Submit the text to the court.
Okay.
He says the column.
So you're a lying liar.
Like your poop.
I ally's okay.
Let's see.
What,
what is that beeping now?
Why is it do that?
It's because you're shooting
so fucked up.
It's all retarded.
Is it going to do that through the thing?
Oh,
was that you?
That there was,
I just saw a missed call numbers at you.
Hey Buddy,
how are you?
I'm a um,
we're doing our podcast right now.
So,
Hey Ryan sickle cell.
Hey,
sickle cell,
whatsapp pride and CP three.
Oh,
there you go.
CP three.
Hey Man.
So we've been having this debate.
It,
it got pretty heated.
Um,
and we needed you to weigh in on it.
who gave you the nickname sickle cell
man,
that's a tough,
should it be?
Cause it's the answer.
I let them let them decide.
Let them think
because
just tell you we both claim to have done today and um,
clearly you both claim claiming or you wouldn't be calling me on a Skype call
Darren.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
Got It.
Got Real man.
We've got a real,
I love the,
I love that this matters so much.
You gave me the horrible nickname I took off my wedding ring.
I'm sorry.
Lead defending it.
Who did it like that will be something that I'm like,
Nah,
you came up Holy Colette.
And I go,
no.
We're like,
no,
you're the piece of shit.
Why Cancer?
And um,
I know,
but we really are trying to claim.
So you don't recall though.
Let's be honest.
Right?
It sounds like it.
I know if a gun to my head now,
here's what I do recall.
I feel like,
I feel like the way Christina says it,
I feel like I've heard it more,
but I really felt like you started saying it first.
Yeah.
That's how you feel.
Cause I do a lot of times I know my therapist has to go with my feelings.
So I feel like,
I feel like he just spoke and dairy Ryan,
I invented it.
Okay.
Clearly you feel like you needed to call me.
Yeah,
I do.
You're feeling
I'm going my feelings right now.
I feel like it was t bonds.
I might,
God,
sorry Christina.
But am I wrong?
Yes you can.
But here's the thing,
I'm malleable so if you can go,
we'll remember this.
I could go,
oh yeah,
yeah,
I do remember,
cause I feel like I invented it and then he was too chicken shit to call it to
your face.
And then I did at first me,
I'm chicken shit to call it.
They call him sickle cell.
You didn't want to,
you thought it was,
I'll tell you the,
the best way to solve this.
Yeah.
After call,
call pudding.
No,
we're definitely not going to do that.
We're a APP.
Do you remember when I came to see your,
uh,
to Brian screening?
Yeah,
the screening and I walked into the movie theater.
Right.
And in unison you both screen Circleville everyone including African Americans
in the theater looked at me.
So I feel like maybe it was a joint venture.
Really
better answer.
That's good answer.
The maiden voyage or we were going through all nick,
the reason,
and we're going through nicknames that we have for family,
for friends,
and that's how it came up.
And you actually just brought up one you didn't even bring up was buns.
Obviously you call me,
you call me buns sometimes fun your buns.
Busay bunzee sometimes.
Yeah,
yeah,
that all up.
Yeah.
Bonds a bond.
Fun.
I remember those.
He used to leave me voicemails.
Ryan would call me and it would just,
it would go to voicemail and I press play and it'd be like,
okay,
I'm calling for bonds.
And he would leave a long message about like,
I'm out on a fishing boat and this guy,
this guy taps me on the shoulder.
I mean,
I couldn't believe some guys swam up to me and he said,
I'm looking for buns.
And that would be the [inaudible] Leo.
Yeah.
You leave me these elaborate messages about looking for buns.
Tenets.
I got socks and balls and dicks and taints.
I liked that one.
Um,
t bonds came from Tommy bonds,
which comes from the movie belly where Dmx,
Dmx plays a character named Tommy buttons.
So in College,
Huh?
I'm going to ask you back.
Yeah.
When is the first part you said Tom,
you say you created,
yeah,
pickle here are the originator.
So when,
when was the first time you remember calling me that and same question for you,
Chris.
The first time I remember calling you that I honestly can't remember.
I mean it would be like,
it would have to be back around.
Oh my God.
Probably 2004 or something.
Three or four.
No.
When did you start dating?
You and I started dating around that time.
Yeah.
More.
Your and I started dating more,
I would say Ledo for early oh five.
Interesting.
And right around the time the nickname originates.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Well that's right around the time I started,
you know,
hanging out with Ryan a lot too,
so,
oh,
oh you guys weren't friends before?
Yeah,
we were.
Okay.
I said,
Oh,
three Oh four,
I think it came around the Putin time,
the Putin era,
putting another nickname of a great man.
Um,
yeah,
more nicknames.
I can't take credit.
That's our high school football coach.
Do you remember that?
I love that.
The story behind that is one of my favorite nickname stories.
It's just that basically Ryan's old roommate was playing high school football,
goes to his coach,
which is,
it's better if you really imagine how pathetic this is that a player went up to
a coach and was like,
all these guys have nicknames.
I want to nick.
And then the coach looked him up and down and goes,
well it gave me,
he gave an elevator look up and down and then just went poorly.
And then he was happy with that.
Right.
Wasn't he happy with pudding?
I mean,
you gotta be fucking happy what you asked for.
Do you have any other nicknames?
I mean,
sickle cell is your best nickname.
I'll go ahead and say that.
Yeah,
but do you have any other ones?
Huh?
I'm sure Beth goes to a,
an individual preference on that.
But yeah,
there's been up.
Christina says you stay oh three Oh four Putin was oh two so Christina statewide
might've just might've just on a sentence here.
Wait,
wait.
I'm confused.
Wouldn't put in half that putting God his nickname in high school though,
right?
Yeah,
but what I'm saying is Christina said she sickle cell originating around that
time,
that time would have been 2002 which precedes your o three o fours.
Interesting.
I'm confused.
Meaning I'm right.
That's how they originated with sickle cell.
Burkina falls.
And I'm saying wait,
meaning I the,
I say the name origin dates further back in time.
That's not true.
Meaning that's not,
I'm right and you're wrong.
It doesn't update date back to Otu.
That's what Ryan's saying.
That's what your BFF is saying.
Chris,
I asked you when you first remembered you said,
oh three Oh four I asked Christina when she said quoting top,
beginning of putting time
around the pudding era.
You weren't hanging out with Brian and putting an old man,
but listen,
Tangier was happening and I would book you and Ryan every week when we were
doing Tangier.
And that was right around Oh two oh three and I saw,
I know them guys were done in Atlanta.
Yeah.
He says one of his favorite rooms he ever did and I know it wasn't that fun.
And I remember Ryan seeing you at the cat club and that and round there,
that era came sickle cell.
Okay.
That night was when it was really like,
I feel like you guys had just been saying it's a meaty,
but that's what it was born
well walked into Brian's screening and we saw him.
My favorite sickle cell story is when I was working that writing job we were
talking about this
Dina's friend coincidentally happened to work on the same floor to fill side of
the building in parenthesis down the hallway screaming sickle cell and this
little feminine black to that sat across from me named Kendrick,
who I love all.
I could hear him say,
well say it.
I laughed so hard.
I didn't know what to say.
I was like,
isn't that a terrible nickname?
So that I can phrase the how,
how we,
I say it like that.
Back to that guy.
Yeah.
It predates other nicknames.
Do you have any other nicknames,
Ronnie?
Ronnie love?
Um,
that's really it.
I mean my last name,
so a lot of people just short.
A lot of people have shortened sickle cell probably cause they don't want to
look like the idiots that you guys do to sickle.
Not comfortable screaming across the crowded fucking
if I got you like a jacket with a badge that says sickle cell on it,
would you wear that?
Definitely.
I would never wear that.
How about a hat?
Yeah.
What if it's a real nice jacket though?
Like a nice jacket or a nice hat.
I thought you just meant like a cheap wind breaker.
But if it,
what if it was like,
it was like a $1,500 leather,
you know,
Gucci Jacket and we just so sickle cell on there?
Yeah.
Embroider it.
Yes.
That a badge.
Like I'd be sheriff.
Okay.
That's pretty cool.
We got to get that for him.
Christmas is right around.
Um,
do you remember Vinnie Jones?
No,
Vinnie Jones was a,
a British footballer,
right as we would call him a soccer player.
Um,
and here he is in a scene from the movie snatch.
Oddly enough.
Okay.
That's him right there with like the big mug.
Great Movie Guy Richie as you mentioned.
Hmm.
You don't have to second folks
guys good though.
Oh,
he's amazing.
Um,
that's how good I am too.
So second,
but the funny thing is he's known for being,
you know,
he was uh,
like I said,
well known,
not just soccer player footballer,
but he was one of like the,
you know,
intimidators aggressive types on the field.
Fuck people up,
you know.
So anyways,
I guess now he's doing some coaching or something.
It's like he's coaching and we're trying to see where he's coaching here.
See if the leads,
anyway,
there's a video of him,
given what it looks like.
Obviously people are younger than him.
He's coaching them up.
Like what the fuck was that?
Oh God,
code.
It's the fucking decisions.
Uh,
Santa Monica.
Oh,
she was a boy.
He stood in front of you there,
mate.
Why not say you put his fucking do you want,
it's 90 degrees.
It's,
it's decisions easy there.
Then we can come out here.
Then we can go there and then we shuffle it over.
But you sold a bad decision then are you can't tell me you'll fix for free.
You ain't want to fucking rule dot gates was on my bucket of a sudden.
You'll go,
no idea.
Here's all the how bullets for certain roles coming in here and going bang up
that bike there.
You'll find the fucking front one in.
I'll put it in the game too long,
Danny,
for this politics over fucking winning or fucking get off.
I'll get someone who can fucking have a challenge.
Hello?
It's like he's coaching.
What is this high school I had?
So could you imagine this guys,
your coach,
you're like,
wait a minute.
You're the guy from fucking statue
that coming straight through.
Yeah.
And the big fellow,
the off color fed up.
He ain't a bad fucking player.
Oh.
Beside me.
My fucking midfield.
I love it because at least he can pass with fucking blue shirt.
Blue Shirt.
I like to take a pass her fuck a blue shirt.
Ash Coaches.
I love it.
Cursing coaches for sure.
Correct.
Fucking Pawson all over the place.
I don't want to,
don't waste my fucking time on a Sunday,
but Tom in here and when can it off?
Why can it are there on a Sunday?
Oh,
you caught Paul six fucking yards to a fucking yellow shirt.
You'll think you fucking know the fucking status until you've composed fucking
10 yards.
Then fucking listen to me.
Hmm.
I like it.
You will let us come in and then you fucking all it's got excuses.
Don't fit that have been at the level,
the highest level you can get.
I can see you as fucking cig in or can see that old nearly run Daniella
concealed at oldest son's in yours in his eyes is it
might a fucking Sunday morning pub.
I look fucking good
looking around here right now.
I would have money on them,
right?
All you lot sure there's,
there's my prediction.
My money's on them.
Unless you Wayne,
come fucking pull yourself out in the fucking bed and fucking get in there and
fucking work hard and when the fuck in bulk and pass the ball or see a Olin
fucking training.
This is a,
I think it was the halftime speech.
I know what it was.
Yeah.
I think it's the APP
breakdown stock or do you know spit?
Oh boy.
Yeah,
that's fucking insurance balls.
Little balls in there.
You're the fucking best player on this side because you get in my fucking voice.
Jail.
Fuck you played it one.
Now it play one in on this.
Fucking it there.
What is this from is so good.
I really love it.
You really,
really love it.
I love,
I could watch just clips of that.
You could tell that he does really give a shit though.
That's,
that's why it's red.
Yeah.
Don't you wish somebody could come in and shout at you after bad standups?
No.
Cause I hear the voice in my head already.
I know I have that voice for my standup shit most days during the day.
I know you're fucking shit.
The internal coach.
Yeah.
Internal coach is like,
I know.
You think that's a fucking good punchline here.
A piece of shit.
Yeah.
I Open Microsoft.
Better fucking punchline is here.
You find out soccer.
Isn't that terrible?
Do you think most people's inner voices or that horrible mine?
Mine's whole.
I think a lot of stand ups for sure.
I think that's one thing we definitely have in common with other comics.
Self-Loathing intense.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I think so too.
I think I got it.
Yeah.
Um,
I used to fuck her.
Fuck.
Oh Shit.
Fuck Shit.
No fucking soccer.
Should we roll?
Which we do you want to do a dental lab date?
Which should we do?
Um,
yeah,
I liked them.
I haven't had one in a long time.
I think we got to find another dentist,
man.
We're moving.
What's going on?
Fuck.
Oh,
he's open pictures of myself on accident.
An accident.
You know,
you wanted to say,
I don't want to see that shit.
I love looking at me.
God,
it's the worst.
Here we go.
I will say [inaudible] doing this show and that's Ebro I'm,
I'm used to hearing my shitty voice.
Yeah.
You know,
in the beginning I couldn't even listen.
No,
wait,
why don't you give me the,
would you rather instead?
Oh,
this is silly.
It's just silly.
Yeah.
Drink
the top layer.
Chunk,
the urine homeless men.
There's times by my buttons
have sex with your sister.
They,
the face grandmother walks on you masturbating.
Never have another orgasm.
Trying to play,
trying to play.
Would you rather?
All right.
This one's a little subtle.
It's not gross.
It's not,
you know,
would you rather eat calm or shit?
Like it's more nuance.
So you have to pay attention to campaign listening.
Yeah.
Okay.
What'd you rather?
Everywhere you go,
everywhere meetings,
you're on the airplane,
you're in the hotel,
you're on tour.
Everything.
Everywhere you go you have to take bitsy.
So that means you got a service,
animal hair,
you got to get a note from a shrink.
It's your emotional needs.
Dog's already really bad and you demand that she has her own area in your
dressing room and she barks senselessly all the time and wakes you up in your
hotel room if she did this morning for no reason.
Yeah.
And you've got to be that guy that carries her a 10 pound Brussels Griffon.
Yeah,
it's,
it's your dog.
People are like,
this guy's an asshole.
You're an asshole.
Yeah.
Any,
it's embarrassing.
And people think you're fucking mental problems or same thing everywhere you go,
every city you go to,
everything you do,
do
you do it?
Yeah.
With your mom.
So easy just became so easy.
I mean I how this easy,
I commend you for like the thoughts involved and for giving it like a real,
you know,
a real go at,
at something interesting and different.
Um,
100% busy.
You know what happens is the bond between a dog and I will grow.
I'll be just more attached to her probably.
Yeah,
she'll probably,
she's going to bark all the time on planning your way into my act.
I was just like bring her on stage and yeah.
You know,
I'll just figure it out.
And she's small.
That's the one thing.
She's very small.
Yeah.
Even a busy shit is small,
you know,
bitsy p a small.
Yeah.
Easy to feed her at.
Easy to get her water.
That's embarrassing.
It is embarrassing.
And I'm walking around everywhere with my fucking dog.
10 pound little shit.
And you're this,
you know,
big dude and I dunno man.
I said,
but I do love the dog.
Of course,
those of us and it is fun to have a companion and she is a great companion.
Love cuddles.
Yeah.
She loves belly scratches.
Yes.
Sweet,
adorable dog.
My mother would would drive me to either murder or suicide.
You know how much I love my mom.
Domain domain?
No.
What time is the plane leaving?
Can you imagine having to manage that?
Manage someone like that?
I have so much anxiety and I'm like,
Oh God.
I'd be like,
and then we're going here.
I'm diet.
I'm like,
I don't want to hear it.
That's what I got to do.
Sorry,
what time is the show?
Do I sell your merch?
Yes.
I don't have a square reader.
Go get one.
How weird.
How do I sign?
When do I saw a mom?
I want to go to the casino.
Go get change.
I don't have no change dummy questions all the time.
Oh my God.
And we have,
then we'd go back.
No,
it's like traveling with a toddler.
It is once your parents get older,
especially ones who,
my mom already,
like she asked questions when I was a toddler.
Like she would be,
it would be insane.
It would be.
I'm really fucking,
when you think about your parents just to generate and they get shittier and
Shittier.
Crazy.
And then you have to,
you know,
like we were taking,
we took Ellis out last night for dinner and he was sitting in a high chair in
the corner of my eye,
saw what looked like a stroller and I was going to look and go,
oh,
look at the other baby.
And it was an elderly person in a walker.
So,
you know,
it's interesting.
You start in a stroller,
you end in the stroller,
you know,
someone's pushing you around at the end of the day to,
um,
look,
we got to get going.
By the way,
don't forget,
uh,
patrion.com/mom put that shit.
Don't do shit.
Don't patrion.com/mom.
Um,
we had to take away a couple of tiers of rewards because,
uh,
just because of scheduling,
it's just too hard to pull them off.
But there's a new episode that's up.
Um,
one,
is it up Friday?
Something like that.
Monday,
Sunday,
Saturday insurer the first.
So,
um,
thank you for all the Patriot and support and um,
thank you for listening to your mind.
What would you take?
You take the dog for sure.
Over your mom or your dad.
Oh,
forget it.
I would take 10 dogs over either of my parents.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Gosh,
my mom was a mess too.
She was a real moms.
Not easy to manage cray cray.
I seriously,
I would have to go to see a,
like a psychiatrist.
I have to get Medicare d after spending a week to 48 hours.
Makes me crazy.
My mother,
you know,
it's funny.
It was that bowling with her.
My Dad hated being with me too.
After a couple of days,
like in my aunt,
I remember the Miami thing.
Oh,
are you going to get out of here or something?
I thought we were hanging out.
He ain't saying an hour with me.
It's funny.
So I,
I couldn't do it.
No.
Very few people.
I could spend that much time with you.
My cousin Julie.
You Know Shawna,
Sarah Burns like few people in my life.
You can really do it.
I know they spend days and days.
I'm the same way.
You have to like Jenny Petland like people have grown up with basically family
isn't on the list.
Yeah,
I'm with you.
All right.
Um,
thanks for listening to the show.
Your mom's house,
podcast.com uh,
Thompson grow.com live shows thousand ranch.com and uh,
that's it.
That's it.
Here's a sickle cell name is mine.
My Dad's balls by gaping dad.
Thank you very much.
And we'll see you all soon.
Yeah.
Nope,
we don't
bark dicks.
Hmm.
Especially since they're such a good size and all.
It gets bigger when I'm pulled them
sometimes
bowling.
It's so hot.
I ripped the skin.
That's a gaping,
gaping dad.
Dad.
That's the gaping dad
had my dad did.
I have my dad's Dick.
I need my dad's bowl.
I have my dad's Dick have my dad's Dick.
I have my dad's Dick.
I need my dad's fault.
My Dad called me up.
Dude.
Things too.
Like how not to rip the skin by using someone else's mouth instead of your own
hands.
Okay.
Yeah.
I have my dad's sick.
I need my dad's home.
I have my dad's Dick.
Have my dad's Dick.
I need my dad.
Okay.
Stepdad had gone up not to be shamed.
Debarge bark dicks.
Hmm.
Her Dad,
Janet.
Jada is not to be shamed of our dicks.
Hmm.
I have my dad had my dad's Dick.
I have my dad's Dick.
I need my dad's belt.
Oh,
I have my dad's Dick have my dad's Dick.
I have my dad's Dick.
I need my dad both
have my doubts.
I have my dad's Dick.
I need my dad's book.
Oh yes.
I have my dad's sick.
I need my dad.
I have my dad.
I need my desk.
I need my dad.
That was really great.
It's so prayed.
Aw.